c'est pas un simple expert de la survie
c'est une aventure à lille
ma vie j'ai rêvé de croiser la route
d'un homme comme vous
c'est bon je viens
chaque toit bien baliser le chemin
c'est vraiment plus court pourra-t-on à
cascade ces mois là bas je suis pas
carté au look d'accord cartographes oui
bon en amérique du sud ont du talent ton
blog excusez-moi des bilingues
surtout face à lemond ban ki moon
[Musique]
ce que je vous demande
on est à l'endroit où vous avez trouvé
cette sacoche
cette sacoche appartenait à mon père
j'avais brodé la jolie brune est monté
au kursaal la salle du
il va vraiment falloir me laisser le
temps de retrouver mes repères la
dernière fois je suis venu si j'étais
seul en plus c'était l'hiver donc savait
rien à voir c'est l'hiver c'est pas
l'hiver cissé c'est l'hémisphère sud on
est en hiver puis des moufles non j'ai
un bonnet je vais pas en hiver la maison